the Joe Rogan experience it's a great
thing to do to go back and review it
just to kind of give the people that are
fans this this sense of you know what it
was like for you guys and what it's like
to see it again and and just to put it
in the context in history when that's
the show that started off these kind of
shows when you think about the shows
that you have today like the Ozarks and
all these different like really kind of
wild shows where you have to follow one
episode to the next and you have to know
what just happened to pay attention to
the new episode the soprano started that
[ __ ] yeah that was and it was also the
first show where there was a real
antihero yeah and it was also bringing a
cinematic quality to television oligo to
the movies for even anomalistic quality
well in a sense better because you could
do it over the course of many hours you
weren't limited by an hour and a half
two hour time frame you could do it over
the course of multiple hours right and
he wasn't you know listen he was a
overweight balding guy he wasn't your
typical leading man like he was sexy
just like they loved them I told you we
used to say TV doesn't put 50 used to
say all the time you know they used to
say TV puts 10 pounds over on you I say
it it takes 50 pounds off you
well there was something about his
character I mean first of all he was a
phenomenal actor like always always was
I mean he was [ __ ] insane and
everything he did true romance I mean
you just go back through his whole
history of his career but that show
doing Tony Soprano
just [ __ ] synched whatever it was
yeah look those moments when the actor
and the role really comes back and a
great role really come together cuz they
don't always they don't always
he was [ __ ] perfect for that role and
you know you see him like there's scenes
and now I look at it kind of differently
obviously then back then you know back
then I was just trying not to get
[ __ ] killed you know now you you're
watching it and in in one scene right
there's some incredible scenes where
he's happy
mad furious in in one three-minute scene
he goes to four different emotions yeah
he's amazing you know you know like
anything you start to see what you have
like what are these actors bringing you
know what are they're playing to their
strengths and what kind of qualities
they're bringing to it you know just
like there's that one scene in the pilot
where at the end towards the end of the
pilot and like my character tells Tony
Soprano oh I can go to Hollywood and
sell my story or some and he in the
script it was kind of he was like
fatherly like you don't want to do that
and sell out you got to stay with us and
build the family or whatever and instead
Jim just grabs me you know by the throat
or something like that it became very
menacing and very intimidating and he
released you know and I think David saw
that was like oh wow that's the guy
that's the character and it probably
influenced how he took the story and how
he would write it but I think a lot I
think a lot of the tone was already in
his head but seeing what the actors were
bringing to it I think you know
influenced a lot Gandolfini was so
[ __ ] believable I mean you know
there's when you think about a guy who
just embodied a role like when he was
Tony Soprano and he's not and he wasn't
like that that's the other thing he was
more like a hippie you know he was very
laid-back you know he wore like
Birkenstocks and like a bandanna on his
head thanks Monica didn't really talk
like that he was yeah I wiped my ass
with your face a big music guy you know
he never wanted to do a talk show you
know Joe I would say why don't you
everyone think she had Tony Soprano why
don't you pick whether it be let him in
or or whatever and show them the real
Jim you're a very intelligent guy I mean
he's not that guy at all matter of fact
he would say to me like before the
season let's go down and have dinner and
he'll Cortile which I ran into you there
yeah let's go down a Murray Street I'd
want to start getting back into the
swing of things cuz he wasn't he didn't
hang around with those guys he wasn't
that guy at all but he didn't he never
did a talk show he did 60 minutes he
do any of the talk shows he said I'm not
interesting he wasn't doing and he
didn't grow up around that he no Jersey
went to Rutgers University he was you
know an actor theater guy I tell you
what's funny you know I I wrote a kids
book called Nicky deuce and turned it
into a movie and Michael's in it and
Paulie walnuts and Johnny Sack and I was
in Jim's trailer and he had the stood
the movie with Brad Pitt a mob movie and
he said Harvey wants the call he wants
me to do let him in I said I don't do
talk shows and and he just calling and
he says he he got [ __ ] nasty with Jim
and said I won't beat the [ __ ] Harvey
Weinstein he [ __ ] calls me again I
will beat the [ __ ] out of him for the
money he paid me I'm not [ __ ] doing
it swear to God and this is all before
the Harvey Weinstein [ __ ] when he was
still the King [ __ ] this is 2012 you
know
[Applause]